foreign
Jackson Tennessee hi Anthony welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
all right uh my question today involves
uh have to do with paying off a mortgage
or saving up a down payment for a new
house my wife and I are we just became
Consumer Debt free and we will have our
emergency fund built up within the next
two months and I just wasn't sure uh if
it's better to build the equity in our
existing mortgage and I think we could
get it paid off within that two to three
year period or just save up a pile of
cash well congratulations way to go man
thank you feels good to get control
doesn't it it does 55 000 in 18 months
as a student loans and uh car loans way
to go that's exciting
yes ma'am thank you so the question is
you're thinking ahead to paying off your
mortgage am I understanding that
correctly
yes either that or getting a sizable
down payment for cash I didn't know
which one would be more beneficial well
once you've got your emergency fund
saved and walking down the baby steps
then you're going to start putting that
15 away for retirement right do you have
anything with kids college coming up do
you have kids uh we we do have a
one-year-old little girl we haven't
really started anything on her yet
because we're getting out of debt that's
right and when the time comes you'll
want to make sure that you're doing baby
step five so opening something uh an Esa
or 529 for her making sure you're
putting some money aside from that and
then when it's time to start paying down
the mortgage I would not do a lump sum
and throw it at it I would make the
payments extra payments whenever you
have the money put it onto the mortgage
and here's why this is this is the Jade
way of saying this because whenever you
have a stack of money just sitting there
it gets real tempting to use oh you know
what I think we might need a new vehicle
or oh you know what we do need a
vacation to Hawaii right it's easy to
think that that money can be earmarked
for something else and so I like the
idea of just piling it onto the mortgage
when the time comes that Waits out of
your hands and it's building you know
equity and it's that for savings account
um for savings that's what a guy used to
work for called it Anthony said when you
pay extra on the mortgage it's a four
savings account because it's real hard I
mean it's a you can do it but it's a lot
of trouble to get the equity out of your
house to go buy a bass boat it's not
hard to do it out of your savings
account and so um it's just you know
you're going to stay on task for the
move up in-house and your your the good
news the weird thing is about paying
down your mortgage it feels like the
money's gone but it's not it's just
saved in the equity because you get the
money when you sell the house it's not
like you're consuming the money like you
spent it or something it's not gone and
so it's just you know what is a better
place I like the forest aspect of it and
uh and the other thing is when you do
get the house paid off
plans might have changed that's right
that's absolutely true and so even if
they don't that's fine I'm not saying
they have to change but if they don't
change and you're going to sell the
house and sell it they'll give you a big
old we'll check it to closing because
you ain't got any mortgage yeah and off
we go so yeah forced Savings Plan it's a
good idea to trick yourself into as many
smart things as you can absolutely yeah
I say automate smart and so when you
automate those extra payments or when
you just automatically put those towards
debt it's a smart habit that's automated
now the only time Dave that I would
stack up a pile of money to pay off a
debt is if there was some sort of deal
that I was getting like with if you had
a private student loan and they said hey
if if you pay a lump sum we'll give you
some off that's the only time I might
stack up well or a 401k loan you can't
pay extra on it you can only pay the
minimum or a lump sum one of the two so
you have to stack up yeah that's a 401k
loan something along those lines then
you have to yeah but other than that I
agree yeah and you know hey guys it's a
good idea I got a bunch of Auto draft
for good things like going into mutual
funds Auto draft going into savings Auto
draft automatically paying everything so
I never miss a discount on all utilities
everything's full auto uh has been since
before it was cool yeah before digital
yeah you know I've been on auto
everything and and you know what I just
said is I'm going to automate smart and
make stupid hard that's good let me call
out something though because I've been
there when you went from struggle slices
to a non-struggle situation back when it
was struggle slices I hated automating
things because I never knew what my
money was looking like and somebody
could pull that money out of my account
overdraw my account and so when we
finally got to the situation where okay
like money's good life is good that was
a hard transition to make it was like
the old brain going no no no no no no no
no and then the new brain has to go yes
yes we we manage our money now like this
is good so it's not it's not I'm not
living crisis to Christ yes I don't have
to control the crisis I can let this
thing flow and so yeah I haven't paid a
utility bill in years that's great I
look so direct you know except Direct
Auto auto auto
uh deduct or whatever the flip you call
it and you know so it's just yeah in I
don't know decades like forever simplify
it and show yeah David Bach talks about
that on an old book that came out back
when uh my first best seller came out
financial piece he came out a couple
years later with a book called automatic
millionaire he talks you know just Auto
drafting into your Mutual on auto that's
the beauty of the 401K comes out your
paycheck you don't even miss it that's
right and uh it's the only reason that
the income tax system in America works
please talk about that Dave you know I
mean if you had a guy if you had a guy
named Matthew
that was at your office and when you got
your check you got cash you didn't get a
check and you had to walk out and hand
Matthew
the tax collector like what you did
there yeah you see how I did that yeah
yeah if you had if you had to walk out
and hand Matthew the tax collector
actual cash out of your check that he
was going to then supposedly take to the
federal government
there would be a revolution in this
country with pitchforks and torches but
the sheep have been lulled to sleep by
Auto draft out of your check and they
sure wouldn't be giving him extra to get
back later as a refund
you know Matthew I'm gonna I'm just
gonna leave a little with you Matthew
the tax collector you look like a good
guy I'm just going to leave a little
extra with you and come April you can
hand it back to me with no answer right
that's a really good point it would end
all tax refunds okay there would be no
overpayment by God because every dollar
coming out of your hand would squeak
every dollar coming out of your hand
would cause anger every dollar coming
out of your hand would cause you to vote
again correctly oh my God and it'll
cause you to fire a whole bunch of
people that can't seem to balance their
books oh my God it would change a little
trillion here a trillion there you know
and then pretty soon we get into some
serious money wow oh wow look Dave I
just want to be able to start a sentence
with my first best seller
that's what you did it's coming before
you I love I love that coming before you
know it my first question before you
know
that's after you've had a second one
right is that how that works that's how
it works well they're coming they're
coming they're coming I got a feeling
Jay I got a feeling this is the Ramsey
Show